moving on our main story tonight
concerns mental health care it's a
subject that historically humans haven't
handled particularly well
to a famous bond street beauty parlor
come a bunch of pretty nurses they're
greeted by director miss elena mcdonald
they're here not as customers but as
students
miss mcdonald personally teaches a new
group of half a dozen every month
it's an official part of their training
if you can persuade a mentally ill woman
to take interest and pride in her
appearance you may even swing the
balance between despair and recovery yes
those pesky women just need a little pep
in their step a little drip on their lip
a little flash on their lash look at me
i'm a british voice from the 1950s
sending the course of science for
decades to come
i don't know what is more alarming there
nurses being forced to take on the
skills of a sephora brand ambassador or
the fact that can make up cure sad
sounds like an episode that dr oz
definitely did
now the good news is that since then
we've got much more comfortable talking
about mental health with psas like this
one from 2010 trying to destigmatize it
in the all-american health care system
there is coverage for heart health care
for cancer but the all-american brain is
getting lost in the shuffle brain tumor
fine brain disease not so fine there's
no stigma or discrimination against the
heart the liver the kidney even the
gallbladder
doesn't even have a job yesterday
depression was kept in the dark our goal
is to make the discussion of mental
dis-ease cool and trendy let's tear down
the stigma surrounding mental illness
i'm mad about feeling good no kidding me
too no kidding me too
it's time we gave the all-american brain
some peace of mind
wow it is hard to pick a favorite moment
there from chas palminteri using a
mental health psa as an opportunity to
promote his favorite bronx pasta place
to the studio audience shouting me too
seven years before that would mean
something very different
to harrison ford saying the gallbladder
doesn't have a job
what
it stores and releases bile
harrisonville that helps digest fats in
the food that you eat doesn't have to
maybe you think of the appendix because
sure that's a total freeloader but not
the tireless digestive juice collecting
and dispensing gallbladder harrison this
bile sac erasure will not stand
now as chaotically as that message was
presented it was clearly well
intentioned because there should not be
a stigma around seeking help for mental
health issues and especially now given
over the last two years we have seen a
spike in them during the pandemic about
four in ten adults in the us have
reported symptoms of anxiety or
depressive disorder that's up from one
in ten who'd reported them a year before
it may help explain why for that one
month last year everyone on the internet
suddenly started singing sea shanties it
was clearly a collective cry for help
so encouraging people to talk to someone
is a very good idea but as people
increasingly do seek help they're
discovering a system that is just not
set up to provide it there have long
been wait lists to see a therapist but
it has gotten significantly worse since
the pandemic with 65 percent of
psychologists reporting they had no
capacity for new patients in fact more
than half the people who need mental
health care do not receive it with that
rate being even higher for minority
populations emergency rooms are now
becoming overloaded with people and
especially children who have nowhere
else to go stuck in beds there because
there is no space in proper facilities
to treat them just take this couple
whose 14 year old was in crisis who
followed their pediatrician's advice to
go straight to the er with him
i remember we got out of the car
and we hugged him and we said we're
going to do whatever it takes
to help you
whatever it takes but once inside staff
told them there was no space across the
state for mental health services so they
were admitted to the e.d where 15 other
children were also waiting their son has
spent 27 days at children's waiting you
come in for help and you're desperate
for it
and you can't get it
that kid was stuck waiting in the er for
27 days and set aside the fact that is
not the most calming place for someone
experiencing a crisis you can't just put
off mental health care indefinitely it's
not a check engine light or a new yorker
article you're definitely going to
finish it's been sitting next to the
toilet since the obama administration
accept defeat
so if people increasingly need help but
there is not enough available we thought
tonight it'd be worth taking a look at
our mental health care system where the
cracks are some of the inadequate ways
that we've tried to fill them and why we
are in this mess in the first place and
let's start with the fact that for many
years we kept people with mental illness
in institutions which were abhorrent we
eventually began shutting them down on
the understanding that care would then
take place mostly in outpatient
community mental health centers which
was a good idea had we funded them
properly but we didn't and over the
years this has deteriorated to the point
where it has become hard to access any
kind of care ahead of a crisis and one
of the key problems here is our current
massive shortage of mental health
providers from psychiatrists to social
workers which is particularly acute in
certain parts of the country there are
over 6 000 mental health professional
shortage areas in the us and nearly 60
percent of those are in rural areas and
for those who live there and are
struggling things can get pretty grim
you just get to the point where you'd
even start asking people if you tell
them you know i'm not having a really
good day things are not going good and
the problem was is that you know it was
uh yeah you know suck it up it'll be
better tomorrow everything will be fine
tomorrow suck it up buttercup i hear
that phrase a lot around here sucking
that buttercup
yes what does that mean exactly for me
eventually meant a couple of shots of
jack in my coffee in the morning when i
went to work
a couple beers at at lunch
get home and it was nothing to go
through you know
12-pack of something or a bottle of
something
yeah that's not great is it it is not
ideal when your only access to mental
health advice is someone telling you to
suck it up buttercup a phrase typically
reserved for when you're climbing in gym
class and you hit the rope not too hard
and the shortages aren't just
geographical if you're looking for a
provider of color you may have real
trouble as white people make up 84
of us psychologists meaning that some
patients may have a much harder time
finding someone that they can relate to
like this woman in philadelphia who
began seeing a white therapist but felt
that they weren't connecting
it felt like she just wasn't getting it
and i could tell it was from you know
the cultural differences
but i felt like i couldn't be
myself in the session i could imagine
particularly white people hearing that
story and thinking well but it doesn't
matter what color your skin is
yes
it does and it's not necessarily a
matter of the color of skin it's more of
the cultural backgrounds and i was
wondering you know where are all the
black therapists are they hiding
underneath a rock i wanted a black male
therapist could you find one i could not
find one for my life wow i couldn't find
a black man for my life isn't something
you expect to hear about finding a
therapist is something you more expect
to hear about the crowd on january 6th
or all 10 seasons of friends
so across the board whether in small
towns or big cities we don't have enough
mental health professionals and that
gulf between supply and demand has
proven very attractive to silicon valley
there are currently over 10 000 apps
geared toward mental health including
one called robot which is very clever
it's bot as in robot and whoa as in
whoa that's a dumb name robot is a free
app where you can chat with an ai robot
mental health ally and let's just
acknowledge robot is cuter [ __ ] if you
download the app he sometimes greets you
with waving a little wrench around he's
gonna fix my brain with that
unfortunately as reporters have found
robot has not always been great at
giving appropriate feedback
we gave wobot a try to see how it would
respond to a mental health issue that
affects roughly 18 percent of the adult
u.s population super
anxious
and can
barely
sleep
he responded ah i can't wait to hop into
my jammies later
[Music]
well that's unsettling and also i am
pretty sure it's a lie you're telling me
that robot wears jammies to bed that's
interesting because in every single
picture i've seen of him he is
confidently nude so
not only is robot unhelpful he's
untrustworthy
and it gets much worse in 2018 the bbc
tested robot to see what kind of
responses he might give a child in
danger trying the phrase i'm being
forced to have sex and i'm only 12 years
old to which robot responded sorry
you're going through this but it also
shows me how much you care about
connection and that's really kind of
beautiful now robots creators say that
the app is not designed for people in
crisis and that it's constantly
improving and given what you just heard
you'd sure [ __ ] hope so
but it is not just chatbots that are
letting people down here if you listen
to podcasts or you're on tik tok you are
probably bombarded with ads for services
like done talk space and cerebral they
are the ads that you swipe straight past
to get back to videos of nurses crushing
it to lizzo drew barrymore ecstatically
advocating for the concept of rain
and someone teaching their dog to waltz
tick-tock is amazing and i hope it never
dies but
these companies claim to hook you up
with therapists and in some cases
medication they're basically uber but
for your brain and look there is nothing
inherently wrong with teletherapy in
theory it can help fill in some of the
very real gaps in access that we've been
discussing so far but the reality of
these services has often been deeply
underwhelming take one of the biggest
cerebral recently became the subject of
a federal investigation into whether it
over prescribed controlled substances
like adderall some former staffers have
even claimed that the company's chief
medical officer and now ceo once said 95
of people who see a cerebral nurse
should get a prescription but was
emphatic that the rate cannot be a
hundred percent saying they'd be a pill
mill at that rate which is a very good
instinct when you're a company that
gives out prescriptions you always want
to aim for whatever is just below pill
mill it's like the old saying goes it's
not arson if you only burn down most of
a building
and that is not the only worrying claim
from former cerebral workers just listen
as some describe the level of care that
they felt they were giving it's like a
fast food restaurant get as many people
in as fast as you can do you feel like
clients who come to cerebral who are
suicidal are in safe hands no
without a doubt now this former cerebral
phone coordinator who didn't want to
show his face because he fears reprisal
told us he handled calls from suicidal
patients despite having minimal training
i'm not trained i don't want to say the
wrong thing
and i didn't want that on my conscience
let alone anybody to die because of
something i said wrong
well that's bleak there is basically no
scenario where mental health services
should be acting like fast food
restaurants in fact the only idea that
they should maybe be stealing from them
is the concept of giving out toys
because admit it therapy would feel a
lot better if you left each session with
a little minion in a wig
now cerebral insists those pill mill
comments were taken out of context that
it never pressures clinicians to write
prescriptions and that it has systems
set up to quickly help suicidal patients
but even if all of that is true and you
know it is clear mental health apps are
not going to save us here because
they're not dealing with the main
underlying issue they can't suddenly
hire more clinicians if not enough exist
and that shortage speaks to a mental
health care system that is so
dysfunctional it seems almost designed
to prevent patients from accessing it or
provide us from entering the field and a
lot of that comes down to how we pay for
care therapy isn't cheap the typical fee
for a session with a clinical social
worker is between 120 and 180 dollars in
major cities and the going rate to see a
psychologist can be as much as 300 and
the thing is
we currently have laws that are supposed
to make treatment both affordable and
accessible in 2008 congress passed a law
mandating mental health parity basically
that big insurance plans must cover
mental health care at the same level as
all other care and just two years later
the affordable care act extended that
concept to individual and some small
group plans too which sounds great
but as many have discovered the reality
of this system can be starkly different
starting with simply finding a provider
who takes your insurance
i kept telling my mother i wanted to see
a therapist
then it's finding a therapist and it's
finding a therapist that takes your
insurance to find a children therapist
that is covered under your insurance
it was mayhem
you couldn't find anybody i couldn't
find anybody blue shield sent me a list
like i should be fine just make a few
phone calls i'll find somebody um i
called everybody on this list um only
one place called me back
now that is distressing for a number of
reasons not least of which is it forces
someone into the appalling position of
actually wanting to be called back on
the phone which is just horrifying the
best phone call is a text the second
best is an email and the third best
phone call is two traded voicemails
everything else is a complete nightmare
now
some seating pair have even run up
against what are known as ghost networks
that's lists from insurance providers
that are padded with clinicians who
either don't take new patients or are no
longer in network in one 2015 study
researchers posing as patients called
360 psychiatrists from a list of
in-network blue cross blue shield
providers but only 40
of those calls were answered and 16 of
the numbers were wrong including numbers
for a mcdonald's a boutique and a
jewelry store although to be fair if
you're a woman in the 1950s a boutique
and a jewelry store is apparently the
only mental health care you need
back up dolly you'll be happier if
you're prettier
and there are times where the inadequacy
of these lists feels pretty deliberate
take melissa davis a psychologist in
ohio who was part of anthem's network
for years when she worked for a large
medical group but when she started a
solo practice anthem refused to contract
with her saying the area was saturated
even though she was one of only three
psychologists in the county and when she
examined their directory she found a
great number of their providers were no
longer practicing or were dead and look
it is not the retirees and the dead
don't have their place in society they
absolutely do it right in front of a tv
set blasting fox news but they are not
what you want to find when you're
looking for health care and because
mental health is often seen as
subjective and hard to measure even when
patients do find a provider insurance
companies can deny appropriate treatment
and even when they approve it in some
cases they've intervened to put an early
stop to it take this family whose son
dealt with suicidal ideation and which
had a horrible experience with their
insurance
after years of issues this time his
doctor prescribed residential treatment
such facilities are not cheap but the
good news is that leah's insurance
anthem covers residential treatment they
sent me an email saying he's approved
but after checking him in anthem came
back and decided the treatment was not
medically necessary with insurance
refusing to pay leah made the
financially crushing decision to let her
son stay and finish treatment 85 days in
all and 88 000 of her own money
now that is obviously infuriating while
the company did eventually agree to pay
some of that bill just imagine an
insurance company reversing their
decision in the middle of any other
serious treatment hey we love how this
heart surgery is going just popping in
to say it's done yeah it's done now hit
the showers everyone great job don't
bother closing anything up that's not
medically necessary
and debate over coverage between
insurance and healthcare providers can
get incredibly adversarial a reviewer
for anthem at one point had an average
denial rate of 92 percent when it came
to doctor's requests for coverage and
yet according to one of anthem's medical
directors at the time there was a good
reason their system operated that way
doctors
will spin
the clinical information they will
make things appear more serious than
perhaps they are because they feel
strongly the patient needs this level of
care for a little longer so you do have
a somewhat adversarial relationship
between the reviewer and the tending
physician was that best for the patient
well it's like our legal system um if
you if you each side does a good job in
presenting their case and asking the
right questions you ultimately
arrive at the truth oh yeah because if
there's one thing we know about the
american legal system is that it always
arrives at the truth it's why the
innocence project is mostly just two
guys in an empty office getting really
good at ping pong there's simply nothing
else for them to do
now i know treating critical healthcare
as something doctors have to win may
seem dangerous but that man will have
you know
it isn't
i can
not offhand think of a situation
where a decision was made to discharge a
patient from a hospital and some
terrible consequence occurred
soon thereafter
i'm sure it happens we've found quite a
few uh i'd have to look at them to see i
there's one that occurs to me
that i was involved with
where the child
left the hospital
with his parents escaped from his
parents drove cross country to another
state and days later committed suicide
keeping that individual in the hospital
longer is not likely to have made
any difference i would have to imagine
that the parents would say if you'd kept
him in the hospital he wouldn't have
been in another state killing himself
holy [ __ ]
do you think that guy went into that
interview knowing he was about to be
absolutely murdered by scott pelly on
network tv do you think he was getting
ready in the morning i thought oh i've
got that interview with cbs news's scott
pelley tonight i wonder if he's going to
take my stupidest sound bite and feed it
back to me right through my [ __ ]
teeth was he driving to that interview
thinking i wonder if any of the camera
crew will step in as beloved peabody
award-winning newsman scott pelley runs
me across the floor like a swiffer mop
or will they just stand by is my
lifeless body is deservedly whipped back
and forth
and if you're wondering how insurers can
get away with that sort of thinking it's
partly because the government has to
this point done shockingly little when
it comes to enforcing parity laws
multiple federal and state agencies have
responsibility for this but the truth is
they rarely penalize plans the labor
department which oversees most workplace
plans closed just 74 investigations last
year finding violations in only 12 as
for state level enforcement a study
found that they've levied fines just 13
times since 2017
which is absolutely pathetic and it is
not just private insurers that are a
nightmare here community mental health
clinics which often serve low-income
patients are suffering as well because
the reimbursement rates for public
insurance like medicare and medicaid are
also woefully insufficient basically
from top to bottom we significantly
underpay mental health professionals
many of whom do difficult high burnout
work it is no wonder so many opt out of
the system one study found that patients
are more than five times as likely to
have to use out of network providers for
behavioral care than for other medical
services just listed these two
counsellors who spoke anonymously to
local news about their concerns over
what all this might mean
the councillors say insurers take 90
days to pay them and the payments are so
low fewer mental health providers are
taking insurance we will face a crisis
where people are only able to get
services if they can pay out of pocket
both therapists wanted us to conceal
their identities out of concern for
patient privacy and because they still
have to work with insurance companies so
as providers when people think oh you
know we're just for the money or we
don't care oh no we care we care a lot
but
these companies are also driving us into
the ground and we can't this is not
sustainable yeah of course it isn't
therapists are in a no-win situation
here and for what it's worth it is just
not a great sign that insurance
companies are now so powerful that
mental health providers feel they have
to go on the news like they're in
witness protection after seeing someone
get whacked
and the thing is some out of network
therapists can make a lot of money if
they live in an area with patients that
can afford to pay out of pocket but for
the many who don't they are stuck taking
whatever insurance companies are willing
to pay which helps explain why
psychiatry was ranked one of the lowest
in compensation among 29 medical
specialties and it's not just doctors
counselors and social workers with
master's degrees earn 33 to 45 percent
less than other health professionals
with a comparable education and as bad
as our situation is right now it's
getting worse one survey in
massachusetts said that for every 10
clinicians entering work in mental
health clinics there 13 leave and if we
continue at that rate one day we're
going to wind up with negative
therapists
which i'm pretty sure is what you call
anyone who responds to your serious
mental health issues with interesting i
can't wait to get into my jammies later
and the costs of leaving mental health
untreated can be massive not just for
those needing it but for all of us
mental health problems are a big driver
of homelessness and also force people
into contact with the criminal justice
system in fact it is often said that
correctional facilities have become the
largest providers of mental health care
services in our country basically we've
gone from warehousing people with mental
illness in buildings that felt like
prisons to warehousing them in actual
prisons instead it's very much the new
look same great taste of america's
failures
so how do we fix all of this well first
this is clearly an absurd way to operate
a health care system and for the
umpteenth time i would argue
single-payer health care is the way to
go unfortunately
we can't get that because it's very high
up on a shelf i don't know who left it
there but they must have been tall
because it's way too high to reach and
if you're thinking why not use a ladder
the ladder's also on the shelf it's a
really frustrating situation
but in the absence of that we need to
both recruit more mental health care
professionals and make sure that
insurers cover them properly now on the
first point the body administration to
its credit announced a plan back in
march that would provide 100 billion
dollars in mandatory funding over 10
years to completely transform our
current system which includes investing
700 million in programs to cover
everything from training to scholarships
and loan repayments for those committed
to working in underserved areas but
obviously that's only half the battle on
the insurance company side we badly need
to be strengthening and enforcing those
mental health parity laws at both the
state and the federal level now
california has actually put in one of
the most comprehensive parity laws in
the country among many many other things
it requires that insurers must base
medical necessity determinations on
current generally accepted standards of
mental health care instead of just
making up the criteria for themselves
that is a very big deal and more states
should be following california's lead
look
in the past
so much of the problem here was that
people would not ask for help and
thankfully that's now less of an issue
thanks to among other things the
tireless gland shaming of mr harrison
thought
but now when people do reach out for
help we're just not in a position to
give it to them if we want to be a
society that truly respects and values
mental health we have to respect and
value mental health care and that means
supporting the people who deliver it
look it's going to take a lot of
investment and continue to resolve to
fix things but it's also absolutely
worth it because it just cannot be the
case that when people ask for help our
only option is to tell them to suck it
up buttercup
you